la oración anti Putin de las ha
encontrado un nuevo eco en la guerra en
Ucrania estas activistas rusas eligieron
un lugar simbólico de la capital para
dar voz a sus preocupaciones la gran
catedral ortodoxa del cual brandy que
depende directamente de la embajada rusa
mucha gente piensa que los rusos están a
favor de la guerra pero esto no es
cierto para ponerse hay muchos queremos
decirlo abiertamente allí donde todavía
es posible porque desgraciadamente no es
así en la Rusia actual
quiero que Putin sea juzgado y que sus
crímenes sean puestos en conocimiento de
todo el mundo para que su régimen se
derrumbe definitivamente lo antes
posible
y no esperaba radicarse en Francia pero
movilización anunciada por Vladimir
Putin debe ser enviado por la fuerza
Ucrania acaba de solicitar
Esta movilización es un desastre lo que
dicen en la televisión que solo son
300.000 reservistas cualificados es una
total mentira se llevan a la gente
indiscriminadamente estudiantes
científicos me preocupa personalmente
porque yo mismo soy reservista
otro grupo de activistas por la paz
acude al evento eligieron el color de
luto para dejar su huella
esta acción fue organizada por un
movimiento feminista y antivélico
somos las hermanas Las viudas y las
esposas de este país que matan a sus
propios hijos y a los de los demás
muchos artistas e intelectuales rusos
han optado por el exilio desde el inicio
del conflicto
llegada a Francia el pasado mes de marzo
daya es una ilustradora está
comprometida con la lucha contra la
guerra y censura Estatal a través de su
trabajo
hice una serie que representa para mí la
protesta tal y como Existe en este
momento en mi país
es para mostrar que esta protesta está
completamente sofocada y que incluso la
gente que está en contra es un poco como
estos animales ahorcados asesinados por
nuestro poder
hoy es imposible ser artista y poder
expresarse
tengo amigos artistas y profesores veo
lo que sufren pero prácticamente no
pueden decir nada
recurren a perífrasis casi vergonzosas
también enseñó francesa en Rusia lo dejó
todo para instalarse en los suburbios de
París y acaba de recibir asilo político
el 24 de febrero cuando me enteré de que
Rusia había atacado a Ucrania
en lo que sí
conozco a muchos artistas ucranianos
cuando tus amigos son bombardeados por
tus compatriotas no sabes qué decirles
es una vergüenza horrible
hace unos meses Andrea y se instaló en
el este de Francia este brillante
investigador en matemáticas y filosofía
obtuvo un puesto en la universidad de
Nancy forma parte de la élite rusa a
menudo procedente de las grandes
ciudades que emigró en masa a través de
la invasión de Ucrania diciendo
si no estás en la cárcel eres
considerado un miembro del bando de los
malos que Libra en una guerra de
agresión
yo no quería estar en esa situación en
absoluto
Así que no lo dude ni un seguro
encontramos a Andrea en su casa con su
esposa Marina y sus dos hijas
esta pareja de académicos ha dejado de
vivir acomodadamente en San Petersburgo
para mí ir a trabajar era como una lucha
diaria
tenía que defender un punto de vista o
sonreír y seguir trabajando
[Música]
pero continuar era imposible para mí es
muy difícil respirar el mismo aire de
los que están a favor de la muerte
lo más importante hoy es por supuesto
esta guerra
este ataque a Ucrania
había que elegir un bando y marcharse
era una forma de hacerlo
[Música]
el exilio de Marina y andrey forma parte
de una fuga de cerebros que afecta a
Rusia desde el 24 de febrero
a ellos se suma el reciente Éxodo masivo
que surgió a la movilización parcial
según el diario nos vaya gaceta más de
260.000 rusos han huido de su país desde
21 de septiembre